we are hit with some sad news we are
learning of the passing of hall of famer
and all-time cardinal great lew brock
there's a sad irony to lou passing on
today before a cubs cardinals game 19
years in the big leagues six-time
all-star one of the games great players
one of the game's great gentlemen john
lester started out the year in really
good shape now in his last four starts
at 8-5-5 era he has the lowest swing and
miss rate of any starting pitcher in all
of baseball david ross told us he's got
to get a better angle matt one out tommy
edmund the batter that one's driven a
deep left center field and gone oh
buckle up folks it's going to be one of
those nights here at wrigley field a
weird wind-blown pop-up and a homer by a
guy who had not hit a home run this year
first of the season for tommy edmund
one-nothing redbirds looked like a line
drive over shortstop and like you said
maddie the wind 1-0 here's anthony rizzo
now
two gun bases empty rizzo looking for
his first hit in the series oh for six
rizzo serves the ball to center field
that one's hit well up into the winged
and gone
number nine for anthony rizzo
so the cubs counter punch early tonight
the breaking ball here rizzo goes down
to one knee
going down through it a little reggie
jackson moment right there great
extension
great legs great power
in a day like today you just want to hit
that ball up in the air let that fairway
let it go a pretty good low ball hitter
coming up and jason kepnes runner at
third with two gun the payoff pitch
home gymnast sends a ball out to right
that one well hit and that one gone
jason kipnis connects on his third as a
cub
the 3-2 slider here
to kick this didn't do much
a little cement mixer right there
a nice stroke
and a great result for kick this 11th
season with the indians we saw a lot of
that in the american league and a big
hit there for him and the cubs managed
scoring position two out some clutch
hitting a good sign for the puppies and
here come the cardinals with nobody out
runners at second and third here's tommy
edmond now his solo home run provided
the first run of the game
sounded like a broken back ground ball
for baez will come home comprares
supplies the tag and faders out at the
plate
and heads up play here by uh baez
uh bader i'm sure did not get a good
jump you see the hesitation right there
and that cost him
great numbers for paul goldschmidt and a
real bounce-back start to the year
that one's hit well out to left
schwarber is not even gonna bother
turning around
that's out onto the street a three-run
shot by paul goldschmidt
89 mile an hour fastball right down
broadway and goldsmith knows exactly
what to do with it he's been hitting
fastballs all year long
and the parade continues
for mr goldsmith
and here's rondell rivelo
he sends a ball well head out to right
hayward plays it off the ivy
o'neal cruising around to score
a two-out rbi double
and a 5-3 st louis lead
thomas the third vader at second and
here come the cardinals in the sixth
colton wong the last time up did not
have her productive at bat let's see
what he does here lefty against lefty
colton wong puts it in play
tobias it's short who throws wildly and
scores a run and everybody's safe
and contact is king and this is the
perfect example good cardinal baseball
you'll see
going on contact and as a shortstop you
always want to miss down especially with
the platinum winner over there in rizzo
if anything bounce past
that'll bring up paul deyoung for a
fourth time tonight he has walked struck
out and singled
her ball lined into left for a base hit
7-3 saint louis goes to the secondary
pitch the curve ball and just to get me
over curveball not the good one and the
young mates makes them pay for it off
double for bryant bottom of the 8th
inning 7-3 cardinals cabrera checks on
the runner and delivers a swing and a
mess he strikes out anthony rizzo who
thought he may have tipped that ball
baez bats with one out
curveball strike three on the outside
corner and baez does not like it he
thought that was outside and he's got
something to say to our home plate
umpire and he's not done talking yet and
that brings in schwarber curveball a
swinging in a minute he strikes out
schwarber and cabrera struck out four of
the five batters that he's faced
two outs gallegos is trying to finish
this game right here and right now
three-two pitch and caratini takes a
cold strike three and that's how tonight
ends three in a row for the cardinals
against the team they're trying to run
down atop the standings in the nl
central again our final score
7-3 saint louis